it's kind of funny to think about this
is terrific view that we use in history
of culture and ideas new thought is
really not new for us it's like you know
over a hundred years old even the new
age is way older than you and came about
you know while I word is kid it's really
not so much for you one of the things
that you see happening over and over and
over again in America is there's going
to be religious groups that are arising
that are always going to be coming out
of the fringe and more or less remaining
on the fringe but because we do have
this you know religious diversity and
protection under the Constitution
they're able to continue and expand and
if there's something vital about them
something that appeals to people they
will survive for quite what some of the
movements are looking at died out some
of them actually managed to survive your
book talks first Africans through all
this you know sort of preliminary stuff
it starts talking about what they call
harmonious and they talk about
metaphysics now our mony ilysm it
doesn't actually anything to do with
music per se so that term is probably
not going to read much to you this is
true metaphysics mean anything to you
there are due to any associations with
it at all yep like play-doh okay yeah
for that I like that because I like
Plato a lot because I teach Plato and he
actually plays a role in this Neil
platonic philosophy and you say they
heard you went to college you know took
an intro to philosophy class right you
got introduced to metaphysics is the
study of ultimate reality and you know
whoever taught you can you read some
play-doh and prop
miroslav would you know maybe dig cart
the cart was doing metaphysics somebody
is ringing a bell tia well Lewis took
intro cons Misha these are all
metaphysicians they're all taking
stances on ultimate reality when I got
to graduate school I took a metaphysics
class as one of the first classes that I
was in and I remember the professor the
first day of class he began by saying
now I just want to clear something up if
you here to talk about crystals or the
rainbow or you know cosmic residences or
the music of the spheres this really is
not that sort of metaphysics class we're
not going to do aromatherapy or
meditation or that sort of thing that's
a different kind of metaphysics what
we're doing is philosophical metaphysics
and I'd be like you know Plato Aristotle
take heart a lot of people do mean by
metaphysics what's going to connect you
up with an alternate reality and the
reason why they're doing things you know
with crystals or you know practices
having to do with the correspondences
between different metals is because they
think that's actually going to connect
the individual reconnect the individual
with ultimate reality what all of these
things that were studying in this
chapter have to do with metaphysics is
that they view the human person as an
individual is kind of disconnected from
what's truly real and reason why is
using this term emoni ilysm you want to
restore the harmony between yourself and
the cosmos or you know the ultimate
reality behind things we're taking in
terms of Platonism the realm of the
forms or something along those lines all
of that would be what these people are
calling metaphysics
and your book brings up a few other
terms as well they talk about the phila
Sofia perennis the perennial philosophy
found the mystical traditions above east
and west so you know where are they
going to go for that you know hinduism
buddhism russi this take out a wall with
with some things a little bit later in
the West it's been primarily a platonic
and neyo platonic philosophy we by the
way have a specialist here at marys so
you could if you want to know more about
this he's not mystic but if you want to
know more about this I would talk to
Professor Schneider who is quite
learning Renaissance plateless um your
book also talks about a cultist when we
use this term a call what do you think
probably horror movie stuff right
whatever horror movies about usually
besides the zombie zombie stuff is
usually not so let's do this what else
to be able to more besides slashers you
know forget Freddie and all that well
else do we have sure you guys watch
horror movies someone please what else
what's up I just know that's that's a
good smart thing to see would be but
where is this what has been out there to
actually teach a moral lessons like
never never abandon your comrades
there's sort of escapism right but you
know why are they scary well because
they have to do with this supernatural
write something you know like it you
probably get watch the brain via the
original not the japanese one look like
that the American one only if you use
you know watch it it's really scared you
know why it's so scared because you see
this little scary girl coming out of the
TV with these other people and then you
think you know if you watch it by
yourself late at night oh crap that you
know I know it's not real but something
come on my TV and you know your mind is
sort of playing tricks on you but if you
actually do believe that what we observe
is not all that there is then there
could be an entire supernatural realm it
doesn't want to be hoarding stuff it
could actually good stuff that you know
makes your life better that helps you
you know in terms of health in terms of
law helps you live a more full life so
I'm going to run very quickly just you
know mentioning these these three things
that your book talks about they talk
about Swedenborg and Sweden organism
which is kind of an eel Clayton asst you
they also talk about spiritualism and
then they talk about mesmerism and the
reason why not to spend any time on them
they all died out what I what I do want
to focus on instead would be christian
science and gossipy and self-help so
christian science we're thinking in
terms of the founder of his name is mary
baker he who has a long history of your
book talks about she is she's in aa
seeker she's trying to find religious
meaning she's not finding it in the
churches in the movements that she was
going to and then she has an ear yet or
you know sort of sick experience and she
finds herself cured of it of her
sickness after reading a Biblical verse
and she sort of you know slowly expands
an entire system her views were that
physical and mental suffering emotional
disappointment all these sorts of things
you have to do with getting metaphysics
horrible suffering death all these sorts
of things you have to do
with not realize that there is no such
thing as as material existence that evil
doesn't really exist it's just in our
minds Christian Science focuses on
healing the person says all physical
matters losery real all that is real
spirit salvation lies in the realization
of this truth and working out its full
range of implications and applications
that's what's discussed in her science
and health with with key to the
scriptures he and what the Christian
Scientist them focus on primarily it's
spreading her message and carrying out
healy now this also entail do not go
into regular doctors it's interesting to
your book points out a lot of doctors
were you know not very good doctors at
the time and she may actually save us
some people by getting them not to go to
the doctors with a prescribed all sorts
of terrible things nowadays you know not
quite the same but christian science is
still around they actually publish a you
know very well respected journal
Christian Science Monitor you man
actually use that as a scholarly source
for some of your your writings from time
to time and they they still carry out
their services weekly services consists
in in some part in reading from Bible or
reading from her or text the science and
science and health with key to the
scriptures they have reading rooms
there's probably a waiting room at the
kips am willing to bet I'm not sure
exactly where it is but if you want to
know more about Christian Science you
could walk in and they let you sit and
peruse their their stuff Mary Decker
eater ed was kind of a charismatic
figure she's sort of a representative of
somebody who you know who was both
seeking religiously and probably
couldn't find you know
an application for her talents in other
areas and an entire church comes out
Beyonce we have another female founder
which is where is yeah Lana robot ski
theosophy is coming from two Greek words
Theo's means god Sophie wisdom so this
is divine wisdom and the notion was that
in the great religions and philosophies
there is a kind of wisdom that's being
passed on that can be taught that can be
called out of it takes you know a lot of
lot of work and it's it's it's not there
for everybody so it's not there on the
surface but yes I dig into it and she
claims to he had these contacts with
these masters or Mahatma's the ascended
masters she taught something kind of
similar to Ed in that all reality is
ultimately wanted grounded in
consciousness she also taught individual
souls are going to be successfully
successively reincarnated through cosmic
cycles to approach their ultimate storms
so cool if that's the case is to try
shorten the process and again how do you
do that get the metaphysics right you
can bring yourself into harmony with you
know ultimate reality her society breaks
up into a bunch of different groups
after she dies you could also look at
anthroposophy rudolf steiner or
sometimes if you know its associated
waldorf schools over here is being kind
of in the same vein as that and then
they are quite widespread as well your
book doesn't talk about them that's more
or less in the same yep and then your
book also 2x about self-help there's
entire sections of bookstores called
self-help what are those sections have
any done around in them at all you're
probably not at the a
where your life is screwed up screwed up
enough where you start buying self-help
books but you know give it another 10
years yourself and you might find some
of those things useful a lot of the
tends to be kind of water down
philosophy frankly from my perspective
if you read Aristotle you'll probably
actually do better than reading more
self-help books we read contoured
somebody like that because they actually
knew more about what makes us tick and
how to unser up your life but a lot of
self-help is about this same process
sort of getting the metaphysics right
figuring out what's ultimately real and
then bringing yourself into alignment
with where you guys might have
encountered this is in terms of blog
posts like in harvard business review 10
steps to you know supercharge your job
performance that tends to be along the
same lines itself health tends to be
along the same lines of well if you can
just get your perspective right then
everything is going to fall into place
your book brings up some examples of
like Emil Coulier here we have this this
verbal formula you would actually like
look into the mirror and say every day
in every way my life is getting better
and better I am better and better and
better Dale currently you wrote this
book how to win friends and influence
people and that that Anna do not just
would like rhetorical techniques it also
said well you have to have a positive
attitude you don't have a positive
attitude good things won't come to you
you have to like you know be happy about
the universe and then the universe will
be happy towards you it reaches kind of
a culmination of Norman Vincent Peale
who wrote this book the power of
positive thinking and so there's a lot
of things along these these lines and
they all sort of fit into the self-help
framework and what's under during them
is this sort of view of methods that you
can just figure out what's really real
and how to unscrew up yourself so that
you're not thinking the wrong things you
will actually
make your life better and you will end
up not only with health but also as well
you'll be a happy person